we're told that the central mission of
this so-called fiscal event is to ignite
growth by lowering taxes and cutting
regulation but where is the evidence
that cutting taxes will stimulate growth
at The Institute for fiscal studies say
it's a gamble at bear so is this plan
just a big gamble no it's not it's it's
about asserting that we if we want to
get back to the the trend growth that
this country enjoyed before the 2008
financial crisis the two and a half
percent average that we used to see then
we need to get back to the the measures
that we know work and which of course we
saw during the 1980s and 1990s helped to
stimulate a period of huge prosperity in
in the British economy and that is to
say making sure that alongside clearly a
major program of government government
investment that we focus on the real
drivers of growth and that is to say
reducing the burden of tax facing both
businesses and families that's something
which the Prime Minister put at the
heart of her leadership campaign this
summer and today we're going to see that
translators into action through what I
think will be a really important uh and
and game-changing financial statement
okay well let's take a look at one
element of it we're expecting
um a scrapping of the planned Rising
corporation tax you talked about how
business will be affected but what
difference will that make for example to
growth will it actually work the
institute for Public Policy research has
questioned this theory that low
corporate taxes boost growth they point
out that in 2019 the UK had the lowest
corporation tax in the G7 and yet we
also had the lowest rate of business
investment well corporation tax is just
one of the levers that we that we need
to uh to look at as part of the uh the
drive to unlock growth and clearly it's
not for me to preempt what the chance of
is going to say in a statement uh later
this morning you cited National
Insurance a few moments ago it's
obviously vital that we honor the pledge
that was made during the 2019 uh general
election campaign that we wouldn't raise
at that tax and that's something which
uh the chancellor has confirmed will now
be scrapped with effect from the 6th of
November that increase in in tax that's
worth 330 pounds for 28 million people
but he's obviously going to go much
further than that and he's going to
tackle uh what is a record high tax
burden on on families and and businesses
reflecting clearly the fact we've gone
through some extraordinarily difficult
years but setting out a fundamentally
new approach to go for growth to make
sure that we we win the argument that a
more successful enterprise economy is
good for the whole of this country and
it's that which we need to unlock today
well if you're confident that this plan
will work and growth will be boosted why
has the office for Budget responsibility
not been asked to produce its
independent analysis of what it means
for the economy it would normally go
alongside statements like this well the
obr will be producing a a full forecast
later in the financial year now well
precisely because as they themselves has
said that given this is a short notice
event they would not be able to complete
the usual quality of analysis that they
would offer and so they will be asked to
conduct that modeling alongside uh
subsequent events later in this
financial year this is uh an attempt to
to kick-start growth it's delivered at
short notice it's a great speed and
we've been working on it a huge rapidity
over recent days but it is not something
which the obr can model uh to their
usual to their usual standards but they
will be they will be doing so in due
course but but are you concerned of the
effect that could have on the market is
the pound for example has taken a hit
recently don't the markets need to see
what these policies will do for the
economy and whether we can afford them
what the markets want to know is whether
the UK economy is going to grow and that
is something which the chancellor is
setting are the absolute heart of our
strategy that the UK wants to uh to get
back to those levels of trend growth
that we used to enjoy and critically
catch up with other parts of the world
where Dynamic economies are surging
ahead the risk is that Europe is in a a
pattern of stagnation Britain can't
afford to be part of that and we need to
to set out today how we are going to uh
get to get to a much higher level of
sustainable growth and that's that's
going to be driven through lowering the
burden of tax well if corporation tax if
the rise in corporation tax is scrap
then businesses will be very happy Liz
truss has acknowledged that the
scrapping of the rise in National
Insurance will benefit the wealthier
more labor says that this government has
moved from leveling up to to trickle
down you're leveling up secretary are
you worried about this government being
seen to be helping or helping the better
off more than the poorer people uh
absolutely not this is I mean this whole
term trickle down is such a nonsense and
is itself a uh a center-left
mischaracterization of what this
government is all about we need to grow
the economy because a more successful
economy is good for everybody if we have
a more successful economy then the tax
state goes up that tax is what funds our
Vital Public Services it is a virtuous
circle as the chancellor will be saying
later today we need to get to a
situation where the UK economy is
stronger is more Dynamic is more robust
that in turn makes it easier to pay for
the services on which the poorest and
the most vulnerable in our society rely
and is leveling up secretary I'm
absolutely delighted that we're going to
be going for growth going for new
policies like investment zones which
will benefit some of the the most Left
Behind communities in our country and
help to unlock uh growth opportunities
there so I'm really excited about today
and I'm absolutely confident that a more
successful economy driven by lower
taxation is the way to Greater
prosperity for everybody regardless of
where you come from or what your
circumstances are that's so interesting
because when you achieve secretary to
the treasury not so long ago when the
National Insurance rise was announced
you were a big fan of it so why are you
so pleased that that's now being
reversed well I served the government of
the day and with a new prime minister
comes new uh prerogatives but to be
clear we're going to stand behind the
investment in our NHS and social care
that was announced by Boris Johnson as
prime minister we're just going to pay
for it through General taxation rather
than through a specific Levy so there's
going to be no uh change to our level of
commitment to fund the Health Service
what we are saying is that we want to
have a more Dynamic enterprise economy
alongside it which will obviously make
it easier to pay for that Health Care
over the long term
well let's look a little bit more about
how it's being paid for because back
when the National Insurance rise was
being introduced you said then that the
government had to be honest with people
about the need to raise the money you
said it was simply irresponsible for us
to whack it all on our debt when we know
that's already at a record high and you
said that just amounts to taxes being
deferred for the Next Generation so are
you now being irresponsible whacking
this all in our debt no because what
you're doing now is you're going for
growth alongside it I think the critical
thing is we need to get the economy
growing so that frankly the economic
growth trajectory outstrips that of our
debt and that is what the uh what the
government is determined to help deliver
the fundamental difference between our
philosophy and labor is that they would
be they would be spending on
non-productive outputs we will be making
a statement today which is about
actually unlocking the productive
sectors of the economy if you get if you
if you are creating the conditions for
stronger underlying growth through tax
cuts that's a very different proposition
to just spending uh for spending sake
which is what the opposition I'm afraid
uh remain committed to doing we are
trying to unlock better Trend growth and
that puts obviously the whole question
of how you pay for public services on a
fundamentally different footing you're
talking about a very different economic
proposition and a very frankly bold and
welcome switch to an open Embrace of
growth that's the main the main task of
the ex-jacker
we're told that part of the plans are
these local investment zones in 38 areas
in England which involve amongst other
things liberalizing local planning to to
release more loud for housing and
Commercial development so how much say
will local residents have in the
planning and the building of this
infrastructure in their area well
investment zones are a really important
part of the chancellors uh statement and
I should I shouldn't preempt that but
what I what I can say is that these
zones will only happen where there is
local consent and we've been very clear
about that in the discussions we've been
having uh with local authorities and
Mayors over recent days as we've been
testing the proposition with them
there's I'm delighted to say there's
been a huge level of enthusiasm in those
discussions and uh we hope to be able to
make very rapid progress over the next
few weeks in terms of confirming where
these zones will be located but to be
clear they will only happen where there
is a local appetite for them to occur
there will be no top down in position of
these zones we want to obviously create
the best possible opportunity uh for for
local areas to to get both targeted tax
breaks and a liberalized planning regime
and that's something which we'll be
setting up more detail on uh over the
coming hours
well on the subject of local appetite
for things Jacob Bruce mogg announced
yesterday the government's lifting the
ban on fracking would you welcome
fracking in your constituency well the
key point with with fracking uh as with
investment zones is that it will happen
where there is local consent and where
there is local consent only it is right
clearly that we look to explore all
possible sources of energy generation uh
including Renewables uh the nuclear
industry and conventional oil and gas to
make sure that we never again find
ourselves in a position where we are so
vulnerable to the actions of our hostile
state in this case right so you want it
in your constituency well no to be clear
Anna this is a matter for local
communities and for local authorities
and the planning process to determine
wherever uh this can this can take place
that is that the consent log on where
the fracking goes ahead in any community
so it's not a matter for me or for any
uh MP it's the question of what local
community communities want
and today's a fiscal event you described
it as radical I think if it is such a
radical change to how things were done
before should there not be a general
election and this be put to the people
no the the country at this point needs
uh Clarity and certainty of government
that we had a general election uh less
than three years ago there's a
government with a strong majority in the
House of Commons and there's an urgent
need for Action today that's why we've
brought forward this package at the
speed that we have precisely because as
the world uh goes through this extremely
challenging winter uh driven obviously
by the ongoing after effects of covert
but most seriously by Russia's criminal
actions in Ukraine or attempts to
weaponize energy this country needs
growth now that's what we're going to
deliver and it's going to make life
better for everybody